Bienvenidos a una semana en el mundo el
programa de France 24 donde los
periodistas son los invitados y
abordamos los temas que han marcado la
actualidad de la semana en noticias de
la guerra en Ucrania hoy conversaremos
sobre el colapso de la presa de kahoofka
en el río nieper también comentaremos el
panorama político en México tras la
victoria de Morena en las elecciones
estatales del Estado de México también
comentaremos a la nueva acusación penal
contra el expresidente Donald Trump en
el marco de la carrera por la nominación
del partido republicano y finalmente
hablaremos del sorprendente fichaje de
Lionel Messi para el inter miaming Pero
antes demos paso a nuestros invitados
hoy contamos aquí en el estudio de Franz
24 con Laura Bonilla ella es periodista
y subdirectora de la fundación pares en
América Latina Laura bienvenida
Muchísimas gracias Rosa y muchas gracias
También a la audiencia Laura le pregunto
con Qué tema se cierra usted esta semana
tan agitada mira hoy voy a cerrar con un
tema optimista y es la firma del cese al
fuego bilateral entre el gobierno
colombiano y la guerrilla del eln para
mí ese es el tema de hoy totalmente un
tema que bueno hemos ido siguiendo y
segura abordaremos con más profundidad
en otra ocasión también desde Ciudad de
México nos acompaña Fausto pretelling él
es él es editor de la sección
internacional de el economista Fausto
les saludo desde aquí desde Bogotá desde
los estudios de France 24 Muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros le
pregunto a usted con Qué temas hacía
cierra esta semana
localmente por la victoria del partido
Morena el partido del presidente López
Obrador en el principal bastión de este
país electoralmente hablando que es el
estado de México e internacionalmente
sin duda alguna la el estallido de la
hidroeléctrica allá en Ucrania pues son
temas que comentaremos ahora enseguida
de hecho Les propongo que Comencemos por
lo que hace referencia a la situación de
la guerra en Ucrania no porque
recordemos contextualicemos este martes
despertamos con el colapso de la presa
de kahoovka que se encuentra en el río
omnieper un sistema fluvial que sirve a
la práctica de línea de frente natural
en la guerra en Ucrania por lo tanto el
desbordamiento del agua afecta a las
orillas a ambas orillas del río por lo
tanto ambos bandos enfrentados en esta
guerra recordemos que la orilla
occidental está en manos ucranianas
mientras que la Oriental está controlada
por Rusia ambos bandos denuncian
ataques durante ataques cruzados durante
las evacuaciones de civiles denuncian
desaparecidos y personas muertas en las
inundaciones y además una vez más esta
guerra se traslada al campo de la
información y es que ambos bandos acusan
al otro de haber causado este ataque he
considerado un crimen de guerra bien así
les parece recordemos rápidamente Cuáles
fueron los pronunciamientos tanto de que
como de Moscú respecto a este incidente
desafortunadamente Rusia ha estado
controlando esta Represa y todas las
central hidroeléctrica de Nova kahovka
por más de un año es físicamente
imposible hacerla explotar desde afuera
con ataques estaba minada fue minada por
los ocupantes rusos y ellos la
estallaron
y esto demuestra una vez más el cinismo
con el que Rusia Trata a las personas
cuyas tierras ha ocupado y lo que Rusia
trae a Europa y al mundo Este es el
mayor desastre medioambiental creado por
el hombre en Europa en décadas
podemos afirmar inequívocamente que
estamos hablando de un Sabotaje
deliberado de la presa de jacobca por
parte ucraniana este Sabotaje tiene
consecuencias potencialmente muy graves
para varias decenas de miles de
habitantes de la región así como
consecuencias ecológicas y de otro tipo
que aún están por determinar Además está
fuera de toda duda que uno de los
objetivos de este acto de Sabotaje era
despojar a crimea de agua
Laura empiezo por usted hoy los
servicios secretos a de Ucrania
revelaron que interceptaron unas
comunicaciones entre soldados rusos en
las que afirmarían que este ataque fue
acto de un grupo de Sabotaje ruso
propiamente como analiza esta
información pues bueno lo que tú decías
ahorita rosa es perfectamente cierto
digamos esta guerra se Libra en dos
frentes uno que es el frente de guerra
propiamente donde tenemos estos crímenes
de guerra como lo que ocurre con La
Represa de cajofca y otro frente es el
frente de la información en frente de la
información ambos bandos van a estar
sacando permanentemente noticias Fuentes
fake news intentando culpar al otro para
mí qué es lo que significa esto lo que
significa es que probablemente la guerra
en Ucrania alrededor de esa disputa por
la información va a entrar en un
detrimento de las acciones bélicas que
quiere decir que cada vez esas acciones
bélicas pueden estar inclinadas a dañar
más objetivos civiles a dañar más la
infraestructura del otro sin que ninguna
de las partes se haga responsable por
ello y eso me parece digamos
particularmente preocupante pero igual
la Casa Blanca dice que todavía no emite
un comunicado
otras digamos Fuentes dicen otras cosas
muy distintas es muy difícil digamos con
con toda esta guerra informativa decir
sí claramente fue Rusia la que saboteó
la presa o decir como dicen los rusos
fueron los ucranianos desde adentro que
digamos sabotearon la presa claro fa
usto le trasladó esta esta misma
cuestión y este complejo escenario no
que plantea nuestra compañera Laura qué
ganaría cada una de las partes atacando
esta presa cuando afecta ambos bandos
bueno coincido con Laura creo que es una
batalla campal en temas de comunicación
pero sin lugar a duda el país más
afectado es Ucrania Yo diría que el
secretario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez dijo Hace unos días que esto
es producto de la invasión de Rusia
Ucrania partiendo de esa premisa hay un
afectado que es Ucrania partiendo a esa
premisa es que si hay responsabilidad
directa de Rusia pero siempre hay
posibilidad de que haya sabotajes en
todas partes no ya lo vimos con los
gasoductos uno y no Stream dos que al
parecer lo que informan la Cia es que sí
había un intento explícito por parte de
Ucrania para hacerlos estallar entonces
sin lugar a duda esta esta crisis esta
tragedia que pareciera ser como una
especie de Tsunami es el segundo golpe
más fuerte que recibe Ucrania después de
la intervención el año pasado por parte
de
Sí y precisamente como usted dice no hay
temas que parece que nunca vamos a
llegar a esclarecer como la situación de
los sabotajes contra el nordstream pero
precisamente elementos que crean a
confusión acerca de quién podría ser el
responsable de la autoría de estos
ataques es que por ejemplo está presa
alimentada la Península de crimea o la
central de esa polilla no era el
principal suministro de refrigeración de
esa central nuclear la masa grande de
Europa Laura como analiza estos
elementos pues es decir Fausto tiene la
razón en que todo esto es consecuencia
de la invasión rusa Ucrania Pues por
supuesto la guerra es consecuencia de la
invasión rusa Ucrania
ahora Digamos si uno mira las
afectaciones en términos humanitarios
creo que hay balance entre ambas partes
o sea es decir ambas partes van a sufrir
altamente Quizás mucho más Ucrania
porque ocurre en su territorio también
en esta zona de Ucrania digamos se
podría interpretar que este ataque
produce digamos una mayor efervescencia
procrania vamos allí in situ sin embargo
Es verdad que
damos primero dejará sin agua crimea y
segundo la afectación medioambiental y
económica de perder el enfriamiento de
esta central nuclear pues es realmente
dramática y Rusia como país Invasor está
perdiendo cada vez más posiciones en ese
sentido y de hecho Ucrania no acusa a
Moscú precisamente de que esta sea una
jugada militar no Fausto le planteó a
usted una de uno de los análisis que han
hecho analistas alrededor del mundo es
que sería este un intento de intentar a
frenar precisamente la contraofensiva
ucraniana que Estados Unidos y Rusia
han detectado Ya como que habría
comenzado no a pesar de que kiev guarda
Silencio Al respecto estamos ya
efectivamente en este nuevo contexto de
la guerra en esta contraofensiva
ucraniana
Sí ya lo estamos hay algunas cuentas que
ya lo están observando en el campo de la
batalla ya se ven inclusive estos
tanques leopard que Europa y Estados
Unidos también ha dado a Ucrania
y sin lugar a dudas sí puede ser un
golpe estratégico para esta ofensiva o
contraofensiva de Ucrania eh dos
terceras partes de afectación de esta
agua está en territorio controlado por
Rusia y una tercera parte controlada por
Ucrania sin lugar a dudas es una región
estratégica porque conecta crimea con
saporilla Y esto es una de las zonas que
está tratando de recuperar Ucrania
Entonces sí debe de haber algún elemento
estratégico que puede llegar a afectar a
Ucrania en esta contraofensiva pero creo
que el daño ecológico el daño para miles
de personas que piden sus casas como
usted mencionó al principio esta nota es
una es un crimen de guerra
Más allá de las estrategias que que van
a surgir alrededor de la batalla No pues
tú estaremos muy pendientes de esta
guerra que por el momento no da signos
de que vaya a acabar tempranamente con
una negociación de paz todavía las
posiciones son muy encontradas y a la
vista está con escenarios de estas
magnitudes Les propongo sin embargo que
cambiemos a otra información que ha
marcado también la actualidad de la
semana y también marcará la de los
próximos meses precisamente y es el
panorama político que se dibuja en
México después de las elecciones
estatales del pasado fin de semana en el
Estado de México y en Coahuila sin
embargo nos centramos en las del Estado
de México porque es el más poblado del
país con casi 17 millones de habitantes
y donde el partido oficialista Morena
ganó el estado de la mano de Delfina
Gómez no con estos resultados morena
tiñe prácticamente de rojo todo el país
y en una posición muy favorable de Cara
a las elecciones presidenciales y
legislativas del año próximo sin embargo
la gran incógnita es quien va a suceder
a Andrés Manuel López Obrador como líder
del oficialismo y por lo tanto quién se
va a presentar a la presidencia y les
planteo creo que consideremos en que hay
cuatro candidatos pero que hay dos que
suenan con mucha fuerza hablaríamos de
Marcelo ebrard que ya anunció que a
partir de este lunes va a dejar su cargo
de canciller para dedicarse plenamente a
la campaña y por otro lado de la
gobernadora de Ciudad de México Claudia
sheinbaum Fausto empiezo por usted
Cuáles son a las principales diferencias
entre estos dos perfiles que destacan en
la carrera dentro del oficialismo
Bueno es muy leal al presidente López
Obrador No sé no se distancia ni un
milímetro de sus propuestas ideológicas
de sus dogmas que presenta todos los
días el presidente de México a través de
las conferencias de prensa
Marcelo ebrade es un personaje más
pragmático es más moderno yo diría más
innovador más más tecnológico
va a un segmento a la población yo diría
de la clase media y esa es la gran
desventaja que tiene al mismo tiempo
porque López Obrador quiere dejar como
legado a una persona que cuide
precisamente ese legado y creo que tiene
la decisión en claro sheinbaum por eso
es muy difícil que Marcelo ebrard sea el
próximo candidato
y le pregunto Laura sea quien sea el
candidato Cuáles son los enormes retos
que el oficialismo digamos no ha podido
que amlo no ha podido solucionar en este
mandato y que digamos van a estar como
protagonistas de esta campaña
bueno digamos
amlo se le critica mucho especialmente
por parte de la clase media alta y sobre
todo por la clase pues más intelectual
en México ciertas incoherencias en su
lucha anticorrupción Entonces como ese
balance entre sus acuerdos políticos
versus la lucha anticorrupción pero
definitivamente lo que va a aparecer
obviamente Fausto juega de local si me
equivoco me contradice es la seguridad
Yo creo que el gran hueco digamos es la
seguridad y la violencia y la
perpetuación de la violencia en amplias
zonas de México y eso nos remite a algo
pues que no solamente amlo sino ningún
presidente recientemente ha podido que
es el tema del narcotráfico y la
relación entre narcotráfico violencia y
gobernanza Armada en los territorios
creo que son los tres lunares que van a
aparecer en la campaña Fausto como como
ve usted estos tres temas que apunta a
Laura considera que son retos que alguna
presidente podría solucionar al corto
plazo
coincido con Laura el tema de la
seguridad es el principal problema que
tiene este país
digamos que López Obrador es un fenómeno
de la comunicación ha generado dos
méxicos uno a través de su discurso a
través de su narrativa que día con día
durante dos horas impulsa en su
conferencias de prensa y otro que es la
realidad la realidad que la violencia
está desatada muchos de los estados de
este país están tomados por los narcos o
muy influenciados por el narcotráfico y
ese es el gran problema que tenemos en
este momento Si es un fenómeno de la
comunicación si es el primer presidente
que él habla a un lanzamiento a la
población con bajos recursos sí es un
presidente que ha mucho este discurso
contra el contra los tecnócratas contra
la corrupción del sexenio de Peña Nieto
de Felipe Calderón de Vicente Fox sin
embargo es un presidente que no tiene
dibujado un perfil de demócrata no se
reúne con oposición es un presidente que
se desconecta de los órganos autónomos
no existe transparencia es un presidente
que de alguna manera ha defraudado
también a un segmento de la población
que votó hace cinco años por él
precisamente porque quería algo nuevo
sin embargo sí es el tema de la
inseguridad su principal problema que va
a heredar y el tema de la corrupción que
yo creo que no está arreglado está
todavía presente en varios segmentos de
el escalafón político y Fausto
precisamente
usted lo decía es un fenómeno de la
comunicación según oráculos en a finales
de abril contaba con una aprobación del
65% le pregunto Más allá de la
comunicación en que ha mejorado la vida
de los mexicanos
bueno a ver es difícil la pregunta yo no
diría los índices cuantitativos que son
los elementos
necesarios para poder responder su
respuesta responder su pregunta no ha
mejorado la la disminución de la pobreza
por ejemplo no ha mejorado la calidad de
la de la vida de muchos mexicanos
creo que ese es el El Gran dilema que es
un fenómeno de la comunicación genera
muchos expectativas y por ejemplo a
diferencia de Gustavo Petro o de otros
presidentes de la región veo que sus
índices de popularidad son muy bajos eh
borich Por ejemplo pero en el caso del
presidente de México sigue muy muy
elevado y ha cometido decisiones muy muy
irracionales como es la venta del avión
que nunca existió hasta hace poco tiempo
y de una manera muy poco transparente la
destrucción de la construcción del
aeropuerto hace cinco años que ya tenía
un 50% de adelanto Ese es el gran
problema de López Obrador
y Laura usted me estaba comentando que
quería Añadir algo al análisis de Fausto
en este aspecto Sí es que me encanta la
política comparada también en eso tengo
algo que decir Y es Mira Cuál es la
diferencia entre digamos tres fenómenos
de opinión como fueron Gustavo Petro
amlo boric porque amlo tiene altas
cifras de popularidad y los otros dos no
hay una diferencia entre los tres y Es
la rapidez con la cual amlo presentó
victorias tempranas a la opinión pública
y lo hizo a través de las transferencias
monetarias directas que ya era un
programa O sea no se lo inventa él ya
era un programa con cierto éxito en
México y lo que sucede es que lo amplía
entonces No necesariamente tú vas a ver
esos esos datos reflejados en los
índices de pobreza monetaria o índices
de pobreza multidimensional pero si los
vas a ver reflejados en la percepción de
la capacidad adquisitiva de la clase
media y en eso América Latina es súper
poderosa mientras que estos sectores
intelectuales nuestros digamos de los
periodistas de nosotros que son más
chiquitos nos preocupamos mucho por la
democracia digamos las grandes masas de
opiniones están muy preocupadas por la
economía en el día a día pues
lamentablemente no tenemos más tiempo
para continuar abordando la cuestión de
México en particular pero Les propongo
hablar de otra situación también un poco
paradójica Respecto a los índices de
popularidad Y es que precisamente
acabamos a de conocer en las últimas
horas que sobre Donald Trump van a pesar
a cargos penales probablemente por la
delitos de violación de la ley de
espionaje por obstrucción a la justicia
entre otras cuestiones que conoceremos
el próximo martes cuando el expresidente
está citado ante las autoridades de
Miami por el mal manejo de documentos
clasificados en su residencia de mar al
lago donde los encontró el FBI
recordemos bien sin embargo aunque no
hay cifras actualizadas
las últimas encuestas del pasado 6 de
junio daban a Trump como líder
indiscutible dentro de la carrera por la
nominación del partido republicano lo
veremos lo verán en sus pantallas con un
56% de los apoyos seguido de Lejos
porrón de santis con el 22% Mike pence
que se acaba de sumar tendría el 7% muy
rápidamente porque tenemos poco tiempo
para este tema Cómo se explica esta
popularidad de Donald Trump es que
Donald Trump integró nuevos votantes al
partido republicano votantes que no eran
propiamente O sea que votaban tal vez al
partido republicano porque era lo que
había Pero que no se identificaban tanto
con él Entonces al ampliar esa base
electoral en hacerla más grande esos
votos son de él como individuo lo cual
no era muy común en la política
norteamericana ahí la única posibilidad
que habría Es que pensé que se acaba de
sumar a la campaña entre y recoja el
voto más tradicional republicano que
está las iglesias a la moral cristiana y
que logre digamos sumar ese voto a su
campaña y que se oponía no y que se
opuso abiertamente al asalto al
Capitolio Fausto rápidamente Cuál es su
análisis
logró destapar esas ansias que tenía una
parte de la sociedad de no creer en lo
establecido en el poder tradicional en
las grandes dinastías lo vimos en el
2016 y en esta ocasión Bueno creo que
las elecciones su Victoria le costó muy
caro porque él incluyó parte sus ofertas
o la desinstitucionalización de la de la
política en Estados Unidos y esto es
precisamente lo que le están llevando a
justicia no es decir el haberse llevado
documentos clasificados a su casa tiene
un costo Que para él Quizás en la en su
perfil muy muy populachón no no se
imaginaba que iban a ir sobre de él pero
son elementos que son huellas de esa
parte de la desinstitucionalización y
además que también logra capitalizar
cualquier ataque contra él no y es que
incluso ron de santis uno de sus
contrincantes ya ha salido a apoyarle
abiertamente veremos qué sucede con esta
nueva causa sin embargo Ahora sí Les
propongo cerrar con un tema que tiene su
relación con Estados Unidos también Y es
que esta semana sorprendió que
finalmente la estrella mundial del
fútbol Lionel Messi campeón del mundo
fichó por el inter Miami y deja tristes
a los Hércules que tenían una cierta
esperanza en que pues la estrella
regresará a su casa para analizar esta
cuestión tenemos a nuestro editor de
deportes en el estudio Juan pupiales
bienvenido Rosa Qué tal Laura Fausto a
todos Juan te sorprendió esta noticia me
sorprendió la medida de que nosotros en
seguimiento del futuro de Lionel Messi
venimos viendo Cuáles eran las opciones
que tenía él para su futuro que se
mostraban a priori Barcelona Arabia
Saudita o el inter
pero yo cuando vi que Lionel Messi había
ido árabes ahorita no sé si lo recuerdas
que hace Este vídeo promocional como
parte del acuerdo de patrocinio que
tiene el con Arabia Saudita se va Arabia
Saudita se somete a una a un castigo por
parte del PS por haberse ido un día en
el que el equipo tenía entrenamiento
después de una derrota Yo pensé que ya
estaba todo encaminado para que fuera
Arabia Saudita además esta semana árabe
ficha benzemam además el deporte saudí
tiene la victoria de que consigue
mezclar su liga de golf con la Liga de
la pg todo en el caminado a que todo
fuera ya cerrado para que árabes ahorita
culminara su gran proyecto deportivo con
Lionel Messi Pero además llega no pasó
eso llega la confirmación de que Messi
va a Miami además de una manera muy
particular lo dice el propio Messi él no
puede firmar nada hasta el 30 de junio
porque tiene contrato con El pdg me
sorprendió esa manera en la que él era
una entrevista con medios catalanes él
es por el Mundo Deportivo más que nada
para explicar por qué no va al Barcelona
no fue una entrevista para decir me voy
al inter Miami sino porque no puedo ir
en este momento al Barcelona eso fue lo
que me sorprendió claro y precisamente
le pregunto esto por qué no puede ir
finalmente al Barcelona no Juan y desde
aquí mandamos un abrazo a nuestra jefa
de edición Jennifer que estaría aquí
llorando por esta noticia si no
estuviera al control de este programa
claro lo que ocurre con Messi en esa
entrevista es que se le nota con
muchísimo dolor muchísima pena Qué hizo
él en esta estrategia de para anunciar
su que se iba al inter Miami él el lunes
su padre y representante Jorge Messi se
reúne con el presidente del Barcelona yo
en la puerta en su casa una reunión de
apenas media hora en donde juega con la
prensa cuando sale cuando le pregunta
sobre si va a volver a Barcelona dice
que no pero se ríe todo un poco de
palabras lo que interpreto yo que hizo
Messi voy a dejarle claro al mundo que
yo tenía la intención de ir al Barcelona
y no voy al Barcelona porque en este
momento ellos no tienen las garantías
para ficharme entonces fue eso todo muy
planeado para luego en esa entrevista
poder explicar Oye mi corazón está en
can Barça pero en momento no puedo ir
allá y inter Miami se mostraba como una
opción muy atractiva con un proyecto muy
lucrativo y además me dice aprovecho
todo esto para decirle al mundo No todo
en esta vida es dinero me voy para un
proyecto que me ofrece muchas más cosas
más allá de mi sueldo y precisamente
aquí desde el continente americano Laura
estás contenta de Ver jugar a Messi aquí
en América absolutamente yo creo que
como buena colombiana a mí la gente que
se muda de Barcelona a Miami creo que
están tomando una buena decisión aquí
sigue haciendo paralelismo con Shakira
entendemos no Fausto le traslado también
esta pregunta a usted cómo cómo vivió
esta noticia
Bueno ahí rompo la objetividad y no
estoy de acuerdo con Laura yo soy culé Y
entonces estoy muy triste porque no va
al Barcelona pero hay que decir que
nunca segundas partes superior a la
primera yo la Joan aporta es un
presidente muy malo ha demostrado que no
ha controlado el déficit que tiene y que
destapó con la salida de Messi hace dos
años el Barcelona está quebrado tiene
muy malas finanzas y creo que Messi tomó
la mejor decisión para él para su
familia ya desde hace dos años había
comprado un Penthouse en Miami y creo
que es una muy buena decisión porque a
diferencia del riad allá en Arabia
Saudita pues sus hijos y su esposa van a
tener una vida Mucho más sagradable que
estar en medio del desierto y Juan
rápidamente La parte económica no lo es
todo pero es una parte bastante
importante y este contrato tiene unas
cláusulas de marketing muy específicas
de qué se trata efectivamente el Lionel
Messi llega el inter Miami por un sueldo
que se estima que está entre anualmente
los 40 50 millones de dólares que está
muy lejos de los más de que se estima le
ofrecía al giralde Ramón Díaz Messi
según lo que ha filtrado la prensa va a
tener una cuantía en las suscripciones
que haya para la plataforma de
transmisión de la mls o sea cada vez que
alguno de nosotros pague por ese
servicio una cuantía muy pequeña de ahí
va a ir para Lionel Messi además a días
que en el caso de la liga estadounidense
patrocina todos los equipos por cada
merchandising que haya por por todo el
movimiento de merchandising que haya de
Adidas en esta liga también un pequeño
porcentaje irá para Lionel Messi Esto es
algo revolucionario en el mundo del
fútbol lo podemos comparar con el
acuerdo que firmó Michael Jordan con
Nike hace a finales de los 80 ahora
recreado en la película Air Jordan es de
esa dimensión de lo que estamos hablando
que hizo Messi Messi yo creo que se
sentó con un asesoría y digo dijo Bueno
miremos los 400 millones de Arabia
frente a lo que me puede dar este
acuerdo millonario con Miami al parecer
sale ganando con en Miami estamos
hablando de unas regalías por decirlo
así que pueden no tienen límite o sea
depende del impacto que tenga Messi en
el Inter de Miami yo estaba mirando
rápidamente Messi se estima que va a
debutar el 21 de Julio en un partido de
Alex cap que es una competición nueva es
un partido en el que ahora mismo las
boletas y la más barata está en $1,000
para que no Hagamos una idea la
semifinal de Roland garros de Alcaraz
contra Djokovic estaba en 750 dólares
era más barata impresionante bueno para
ir cerrando este tema Messi no se va a
aburrir en una liga que está bastante
por debajo de su nivel deportivo se va a
acabar retirando en el inter Miami o va
a buscar una salida Hagamos una ronda
para terminar Laura Pues mira yo
sinceramente creo que Messi va a vivir
muy bien en Miami O sea ya no ha llegado
Ya lo aman tiene todas las ofertas del
mundo y pues si la buena vida se mide en
algo más que es la capitalización de los
contratos Pues creo que tomó una muy
buena decisión Fausto
Bueno pues definitivamente a ver yo
escuché una entrevista con el director
deportivo de la mls Hace unas horas y
dijo que ya todos los boletos del equipo
de Miami en la próxima temporada están
vendidos es un fenómeno Es evidente que
sí claudica ya Messi en su último
estirón para poder dar lo más lo más
importante que es Pues todo en una liga
con tan competitiva como la española
Pero también es un ser humano que yo
creo que hay que aplaudirle porque tomo
una buena decisión que no todo es
competitividad y creo que va a disfrutar
mucho su vida Miami Es una lástima
porque yo quisiera ir a verlo pero ya no
hay boletos Juan el reto para Miami va a
ser liderar a un equipo que acaba de
sacar a su técnico es su último en su
conferencia de liderarlo con un proyecto
deportivo que pueda ser competitivo
dentro de una liga nueva en este momento
tiene prácticamente una estrella
solamente Joseph Martínez el venezolano
el delantero el goleador creo que por la
cabeza de México en lo competitivo es
vas a informar un buen grupo que pueda
ganar títulos nacionales e
internacionales la Conca Champions o el
Alex Cup que es el torneo O sea crees
que se va a retirar Messi en el inter
Miami tiene tres años de contrato cuando
acaba este contrato se vendría el
mundial que es en Estados Unidos en uno
de sus anfitriones junto con México Así
que podría ser una bonita manera de
empalmar cerrar ahí y aunque él siempre
ha hecho que le gustaría terminar su
fútbol en Argentina Bueno pues iremos
viendo como sigue la carrera de Messi en
que cuando ya has llegado a lo más alto
todo es un riesgo no de de ir hacia
abajo Bueno les doy las gracias a Juan
Fausto Laura Muchísimas gracias por
haber compartido su tiempo sus análisis
aquí con nosotros en una semana en el
mundo de France 24 Le recuerdo que
pueden ampliar toda esta y mucha más
información en nuestras redes sociales y
en nuestra página web
[Música]